[Música]
los trabajos de limpia
durante 30 años esta voz retumba en el
fuerte boy arte cada año detrás de estos
muros se rueda un famoso programa de
televisión en primavera el fuerte se
despierta al ritmo de los preparativos
de la nueva temporada durante dos
semanas la producción los trabajadores y
los técnicos están ocupados finalizando
los decorados hay 120 personas
trabajando incluso hay voluntarios para
hacer de conejillos de indias y probar
los juegos antes del estreno es genial
lo vemos todo el tiempo en la televisión
y luego allí estamos en el de verdad
vamos a participar en los juegos así que
se sigue disfrutando mucho nos trae
recuerdos de infancia excepto que
estamos en la piel de las personas que
lo hacen con cada edición son nuevas
pruebas juegos de reflexión diseñados
durante meses
emily va a ayudar con el control de
calidad te voy a pedir que lleguen lo
más lejos posible en tu avance a 50
centímetros del final de estas áreas de
acuerdo y volveremos a subir la escalera
toda la producción está a la espera de
estos primeros ensayos permiten ajustar
el nivel de las pruebas
en general necesitamos al menos 10
pruebas diferentes para llegar a
encontrar un grado de dificultad que sea
consistente explotar
[Aplausos]
detrás del fuerte hay una plataforma que
nunca vemos
este es el único acceso al monumento
material y personal
todo sube gracias a una grúa
los felinos no son una excepción a la
regla
cada año tres tigres toman posesión del
lugar para los entrenadores siempre es
la misma rutina
está acostumbrada al fuerte estos tres
están acostumbrados desde hace al menos
89 años ni siquiera recuerdo en qué año
empezamos
los tres tigres son verdaderas estrellas
de cine en la vida de pi
y en dos hermanos de jean jacques annaud
salían ellos para estos felinos que
viajan por el mundo el fuerte se ha
convertido en su segundo hogar
esta es su casa de campo
sin embargo ante las críticas por el uso
de estos animales salvajes el programa
ha anunciado que pronto serán retirados
pero siempre quedarán las otras grandes
estrellas del juego
pase pastún y pase mujer también forman
parte de las murallas llevan 32 y 22
años en el fuerte respectivamente
esta es la fábrica de salsa de tomate
larga vida al tomate la prueban alguna
vez sí pero con discreción no deben
decírselo al padre furas no sabe lo que
hacemos
es un secreto
recorren kilómetros sin hablar también
trabajan con productoras extranjeras 35
nacionalidades ya han competido en el
fuerte libaneses americanos pero también
turcos rusos coreanos
[Música]
pares
en 1988 el productor de jacques antoine
intenta una apuesta loca
compro esta fortaleza en ruinas y la
hizo restaurar para acoger un programa
de televisión al principio se llamaba
las llaves de fort boyard
el éxito es inmediato
por favor
esconderse en la parte de atrás
esta cámara pasan las décadas pero la
receta que hizo que el programa tuviera
éxito sigue siendo la misma
[Música]
genial tiene sentido lo que haces
[Aplausos]
no me hagas reír
todas las imágenes llegan aquí en una
sala de control escondida en el fuerza
en los controles
el director observa una pared de
pantallas y ve lo que cada una de las
doce cámaras está filmando
todo el mundo se esconde somos 135
personas unas 130 o 140 al día y no
quiero ver a nadie aparte del
presentador y de los candidatos eso es
un verdadero reto así es
los 35 grupos profesionales presentes en
el fuerte están ocupados
se tarda ocho horas en grabar el
programa en 15 días deben rodarse todos
los episodios de esta temporada
el equipo de rodaje volverá el año que
viene atraído como un imán por esta roca
en medio del mar
[Música]